I would much rather have a marketing
problem than a product problem because
we have a shitty product
what the hell are you marketing okay but
if you have a great product I.E Ron
DeSantis you can clean up the marketing
so say what you want about Trump he does
not have a marketing problem the problem
is kind of the product
but the scientists in my opinion I think
is a great product but he needs to
relook I think that was a very uh
irresponsible comment about him not
being his being a great not being a
great product
uh he was probably
he's probably the best president we've
had in 50 years
so when DeSantis can be the best
president for four years I'll agree with
you